the next big wave of
change from normal people is going to be
your bank account is going to become a
wallet
right it's going to be a wallet on your
phone a crypto wallet
you're not going to have 72 different
passwords all your value values could be
held in this crypto wallet
and it's it'll be tickets anything that
can keep me from having to remember all
these passwords
is a huge win
i try to use the same one and they don't
work i'm like i am sure no it's the
worst man it's like you've used this
password before it's like that's because
it's my [ __ ] password
[Laughter]
and i think we're going to have a
digital dollar and a digital remm
b and a digital brazilian rey eye
they're called stable coins or central
bank issue digital currencies
and this thing the five dollar bill will
be the
way of the dodo
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks mike
novogratz
joins the pod to speak with andrew they
talk crypto they talk business they talk
what is going on in the world they talk
about his background a bit this guy has
done
he used to be a wrestler um and then got
into finance
and now he's gotten into philanthropy
and cryptocurrency it's a fascinating
conversation between
two just called unique minds you're not
going to want to miss it's one of the
good
yang convos that you know what i'm
talking about so tune in mike novogratz
joining yang speaks
right now
[Music]
i am so pumped to welcome to yang speaks
one of the godfathers of cryptocurrency
one of the foremost investors in the
world
michael novogratz mike welcome to the
podcast
thank you andrew i think your origin
story is fascinating
um where you were you know one of seven
kids um
and then you became a champion wrestler
uh
throughout high school and then you
became like the captain of your
wrestling team in college
which is like a certain kind of profile
and then you joined the military
i became a helicopter pilot like there's
like kind of this
sort of badass quality to like your
origin story
uh and then after that you did something
um that
you know i i'm not sure whether people
would expect at that stage which is
uh head to wall street but can you talk
a little bit about
your formative experiences as a wrestler
because i know even now you sponsor
various wrestling organizations and you
have
wrestling organizations uh trying to
help underprivileged kids
uh enjoy the sport for their own
personal discipline
yeah listen wrestling's been a big part
of my life
i grew up you know one of seven in a
middle-class family my dad was in the
army
but more importantly my dad was this
giant man who had
this giant story because he was the best
football player
uh in the country the best defensive
player in college
and he came from a small town and so he
was like the hometown hero
and we grew up with this myth of my
father he never said a word about
himself
but my mother was a big braggart
and and you'd go to my grandmother's
house and they're all these giant
trophies
you know blocks of granite and newspaper
clippings and
you know my father played on this very
famous west point team where they were
the best team in the country
he met vice president nixon and
had a big you know celebration at the
white house and so
he was this hero and i was a skinny
scrawny kid
uh and he put me into wrestling when i
was young
and it was a sport that if you're good
at you like
and if you're not good enough you really
don't like it and i happened to be a
wiry
strong enough kid and it wasn't that
competitive of a youth league
and you know so i stuck with it and by
the time i was in high school
i was one of the best kids in our school
partly because our school wasn't that
good
but i took this leadership role of
saying i want to make our team great
and high school wrestling really defined
me in lots of ways
i got into princeton because i was a
wrestler i was a good student
and you know i i did an rotc scholarship
and i was the
class president or the class of the
student government you know
elected president and
a complete kind of back in in middle
class high school you had to check
every box you could on extracurricular
so you were in the
spanish club and the national honor
society all these things you never
actually went to but you had to check
the box
um but i think i got it because i was a
wrestler and then at princeton
i realized hey i'm not that great of a
wrestler i'm not that great of a student
like you go to a place like princeton
from a middle class and you realize [ __ ]
uh you know having been the big
fish in the small pond in high school um
but i stuck with it and by the time i
was a senior i was the captain and i was
and i was almost really good but not
really good
let me say that being a college wrestler
i mean these are like the most
strong-willed people around
you guys train and manage your weight uh
uh on levels that most of us frankly
can't continue but then you show up and
go to these meets and i
it's i mean it's it seems very
all-consuming was it like that for you
in college
it's a brutally tough sport matter of
fact my youngest kid
nacho who's a beautiful funny kid and
he's smart and great athlete
i want him to wrestle he's like why
would i wrestle it's too hard
and i was like yeah that's that's the
curse of privilege baby
um it's a hard sport you get beat up all
the time
but i tell you what through the cauldron
of the hell you go through
comes leadership because leadership
comes from
discipline and toughness and it's not
like a fake toughness it's a real
toughness because it really does suck
when you're sucking at weight and you're
tired and you don't want to do it
anymore you're getting the heck pounded
out of you
and so you learn to lean into things you
learn to not be scared
and that's where leadership comes i
wrestled for one year in eighth grade
i was not good uh and it was very very
difficult and i have so much respect for
everyone who wrestled
competitively for years and years in
high school and college and even beyond
uh it really is such like a
testament to what mind over body can
could do because you know you have to
just take so much punishment and put
your body through so much
and you and i bonded over the fact that
both of us are
mma fans in part because we know what
some of these athletes go through
uh you know in order to to compete at
that level
i think that high level wrestlers can do
anything under the sun i mean that there
was a guy
that uh dan bloom if you're listening to
this uh who we
had in the first class adventure for
america who was like a
near championship level wrestler at
wesleyan and
he could you know he could just make
himself do anything because
of that discipline so in your case you
took that discipline to the military you
were in the
um national guard and served as a
helicopter pilot um and saw i think a
lot of the country i remember talking to
you about
some of your experiences in in various
bases
i had an rtc scholarship go to school
and
i was in some ways lucky
that reagan realized he had over built
up the army
and there was a peace dividend coming in
1988 so he
allowed people who were supposed to
serve full-time to
join the national guard and so
i was scared if i was going to the army
i want to do something fun
and so i applied for flight school and i
decided you know i got accepted to
flight school
um but instead of spending six years in
the real army i did 18 months of
active duty learning how to fly
helicopters to be an officer and then i
had a commitment to the national guard
where i
flew around jersey and defended the
great state of new jersey
um and it was funny i
am a politics buff in an economics buff
and really didn't believe we would ever
go to war again there was glasnost in
1989 we were making
friends with the soviets and in the army
it was
all about tank warfare and i was like
you guys aren't reading the newspaper
and so one of the reasons i was happy to
go in the national guard is i didn't
think we'd ever go to war
and i didn't want to prepare to be on a
baseball team and practice practice
practice and never play in a game
and so i joined the national guard i go
to new jersey and sure enough
right afterwards saddam invades kuwait
and there's desert storm one and my
friends from the army are all
fighting in the war and i had that young
sophomoric
feeling of i can't believe i missed my
chance to like defend the country and be
in war
i mean looking back on it that was kind
of an idiotic thought because war sucks
but in that moment i felt like oh and
i'm flying around new jersey
and people are saluting me and cheering
you and i felt like one of the great
frauds of all time
and it wasn't until later i was talking
to
an army general and he was like son you
raised your right hand
and swore to defend the constitution and
that's enough for me
like most people don't do that you
weren't asked to go if you were asked
you would have gone
and and so it actually helped put in
perspective
like what service is like everyone
doesn't you know serve the same way
uh but when i was that age i kind of
felt schmucky
uh listen flying helicopters is is fun
uh part of the army i think everyone in
the country should go through
something like that it bonds you with
you know people from all over the
country from different races different
economic groups it's one of the great
uh desegregators in lots of ways because
you're all the same you're in crappy
quarters you're eating crappy food
you're wearing the same uniform and so
it doesn't matter if you're
rich poor white black chinese korean gay
or straight
you know you're you're waking up at 5am
which sucks for everybody and
you know listen to the bugle and lining
up and get yelled at
well you know obviously there are some
other countries where they do have
mandatory military service
no israel is probably the one that pops
mine for most people
where my parents grew up in taiwan there
was mandatory military service for
for most people and you spent a certain
number of months
and i'm with you that that kind of
experience
does give you more of a sense of
egalitarianism and it's like look we're
all just
you know in the same boat i have to
put on our uniforms and clean the bed
and do whatever needs to be done
so you transition at that point to wall
street where you had a long and storied
career
it started at goldman took you around
the world i think in
different times and then you went on to
to join various hedge funds that you
originated in some cases do you want to
talk a little bit about your arc on
wall street like what what it was like
showing up on day one
yeah listen i remember interviewing
first i was interviewing for an
investment banking job and
you know i was two years behind my class
if you think about it right
i was 24 that so the 22 year olds who
had gone through that grueling
two years of investment banking the one
kid says well
why do you think you're tough enough to
survive on wall street and i was like
that'd be nice and i was like well when
you're flying helicopters and the
enemy's coming and you're
calling an air fire stuff i had never
done
you know i was like come on dude
i realized early on that
a lot of success in life is having
confidence
and a lot of success on wall street is
having confidence
and then being in the right seat at the
right time and i got lucky a couple
times now people say you make your own
luck and part of that
is true um i worked for a great boss
originally uh george weldy
in one of the easiest jobs on wall
street which was selling money market
securities
and so it was a great transition because
if you were a natural salesman it was
really easy because it was like selling
vacuum cleaners
and i was like this isn't so hard and
then i had a boss
his boss who liked me who said dude i
want you to go to japan
uh and i said can i talk to my
girlfriend think about it and he waited
about 30 seconds he's like no
okay i'm going to japan you know that
was a defining part of my career because
now i was the young guy in a foreign
land
and you either have the confidence to
call back to your boss or tell people
what you think
what you're seeing um and so
i happen to be there where it was an
amazingly interesting time in the
japanese bond market
i was the first white guy at goldman
sachs that worked in that group
and so the japanese were unbelievably
nice to me i had my own translator
um and you know try to learn the
language
and then move to hong kong uh the next
year
to run our trading business and
it was a little bit right place at the
right time the world blew up in asia i
don't
you know for people that are not as old
as me there was a
financial crisis in asia in 1997
where asia really had this meltdown
moment
and i realized you can't be a five-star
general in the army
unless you're in a war and i was in a
financial war
and you can either be run over and
bayonet and killed or you can get
promoted
and you know you've turned left you're
getting bait and energy turned right
you're getting
promoted and so uh i was lucky enough in
some ways
to have great support and have the right
skills to survive
but really lucky enough that i was in
this kind of chaotic war
which really accelerated my my
trajectory at the firm
you know if i was selling mortgages in
dallas i'd probably still be here
selling mortgages in dallas
and so there's a lot of luck involved
and what seat you're in at the time and
do you take advantage of that seat
but that experience
i learned empathy in terms of empathy by
means it's like you realize your way of
life is just a way of life it's not the
way of life
it's like people in other culture
cultures think differently live
differently
um i had economic empowerment because i
made lots of money for the firm and then
got promoted
and that built my confidence and i
realized
yeah like wrestling i wasn't the best
but this is a game if you work hard at
it and you let your confidence build you
can
succeed at it and that kind of set me up
for the next couple chapters of my life
um and a lot of it is just the
confidence of winning at some things
uh you know you realize i remember
one of the things i thought was so cool
in princeton was after my second year i
realized
yeah i wasn't a rich kid and i came from
middle class school but
everyone kind of uses the same toilet
you know chases the same girls drink the
same beers
and so you start level setting and
saying they're not that much more
special
special than you are and then you get
one little win and you're like well
that's more special than me at all and
it was kind of the same thing in goldman
sachs there was a
there was this mystery that gets
demystified once you get there
you know mike i had a similar situation
uh when i was running venture for
america
where i met
president obama former president clinton
former president bush half a dozen
governors half a dozen senators
and they were good people or seeming
people
they seemed smart and skilled in their
way
but they didn't strike me as frankly
being
otherworldly or any better
than like other people and they also
didn't fill me with this sense like oh
we've got this covered like these people
have it all under control like
it was more like oh these people are
just people
just like me and other people i know and
you know that like
a lot of their schedules are
unfortunately kind of predetermined and
like
i don't have the sense that some of the
big problems bearing down on us are
going to get addressed and in my case it
was about
the progressive automation of labor you
could put climate change in there you
could put like a bunch of things in
there
and so i had like a similar experience
where when you get exposed to
uh to people in different environments
and you put your
hat in the ring then you're like wait
like oh wait a minute like i can do a
lot of the same things these people can
do
uh and i i think that's something that i
wish more people had like if you have
that kind of exposure combined with
confidence and then a little bit of
success
then you can build on it um though you
and i guess we can tell the story
because it's funny like i came to you as
like hey i'm running for president and
you were
i had this predetermined nation just
what a president is supposed to be and
he was older than you
and more experienced and more successful
in terms of whatever i meant by success
well you had to have been a senator
i'm just a dude and of course having now
met all the candidates you're like
yeah i was wrong and you did a hell of a
job
like really you know hats off because as
i saw the yang gang build and you
you know gain traction and quite frankly
change the national narrative around
how we think about labor uh forget just
ubi
really how we think about labor uh
i was kind of in odds like i kind of
left the guy in my office and
he's had a bigger impact on the election
than almost anybody
you know i read i read an article today
and it was talking about unskilled labor
and it changed my whole perspective i
was like
hell like unskilled labor try being a
gardener and planting a wonderful garden
that blossoms at the right time
yeah i mean you probably couldn't do it
there's still in that
you know it's we should call it labor
that hasn't gotten formal education
but they're absolutely not unskilled try
being a line cook
uh at a fancy restaurant oh my gosh like
i would last
uh approximately 10 minutes as a line
cooking a fancy restaurant and then
they'd fire me
that's not unskilled labor it's very
skilled labor or even
come to a goddamn parking garage in new
york city and try to take your car
out of the maze and get it just getting
the car out of that parking garage
yeah it's a skill set that i don't have
nope
yeah i i saw a guy back into a space the
other day in a garage and i was like i
never would have tried that and he just
like slipped it right in there
so i don't think i would ever use the
term unskilled labor again
well my first job as a teenager was a
busboy in a chinese restaurant and
i you know like these waiters were like
blowing um
blowing me away in terms of what they
could do uh
you know so yeah i'm with you uh and
there there should be a better term for
it
one society i think that has a really
positive attitude about this is
uh the germans where they have several
types of education
um and uh they try to treat them equally
where it's not like
if you have a four-year college degree
then you know you're you're
you're better you're better right like
there's a two-year vocational
apprenticeship
track uh there's a purely vocational
track and then their companies are
organized so that people from every
track are
in the board room can you imagine that
in america if you had someone who is
from the shop floor on the board uh i
mean i think that would probably be a
positive thing but
uh you know but it's not very american
unfortunately right now
no we we screwed our country up in some
ways
you know one of the things i'd like to
think about or when i think
why when we when i grew up i'm older
than you
uh if you were the janitor
at ibm you worked for ibm
you could use their college plan if they
paid for college at night you got
benefits
and now all the service employees from
apple
google and everywhere else uh are
contracted employees
they don't get the health care they're
not ibm employees anymore that's right
and that's a that's a real sad statement
because when you think about
how to build community how to help
social mobility how to
take care of people you want to feel
like you're on the same team
our economy has evolved in very very
specific ways
where it's become hyper efficient and
specialized and if it's not in your core
competence then you want to hire some
service and then at this point the
service consists of
gig workers who get parachuted into your
environment and that's considered smart
business but i agree with you we've lost
something fundamental where you have
like a company picnic and everyone's
there including the person and then you
can actually go
from the mail room to like positions of
real responsibility and it wasn't as
credentialed as it is now
today's episode of yank speaks is
brought to you by our sponsor
better help guys i cannot emphasize this
enough
take care of your mental health i
started doing it myself
and better help has literally changed my
life and changed how i operate on a
daily basis so what is it
it is a private secure way to talk to
professional counseling
securely online um so you can send a
message to your counselor anytime
you get paired with someone up to 48
hours you start chatting
and you don't have to sit in the
uncomfortable waiting room it's all
online it's all personal and private and
you can talk about
whether you got depression or stress
anxiety relationships sleeping
lgbtq matters grief self-esteem you name
it for me it's just about
staying focused pulling off some steam
and talking about all the things that
are on my mind during the week
so i want you to start living a happier
life today and as a listener you'll get
10 percent off your first month by
listening to our sponsor betterhelp.com
yang join over one million people have
taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelp.help.com
so it's funny because you and i were
joking about this before
mike that when i was in your office
saying i'm going to
run for president um like i joked that i
was like the cryptocurrency of
presidential candidates because it was
like the thing that like you know some
people didn't see value in and then it
ended up
uh you know doing something so when did
you first
find out or hear about cryptocurrency
and then what was it that spurred you to
make like a significant investment that
now
has in my opinion just you you
single-handedly helped change the
trajectory
and history of what cryptocurrencies are
and how they're perceived
but like do you remember the first time
someone came to you
so a buddy called me up and he said dude
have you heard of bitcoin i said i said
do me a favor and look into it and so i
googled it i
asked some guys on my desk and it took
me about an hour to realize
it's going to go higher and it was
trading this was 2013 it was trading at
95 dollars and
there were lots of reasons i thought it
would go higher it
resonated with libertarians uh we were
in 2012
the european financial crisis coming off
the back of the great financial crisis
and there was all this worriness
around quantitative easing right ben
bernanke was the central bank governor
and he was printing lots of money
and so lots of very smart people thought
we would have hyperinflation
uh they didn't know the tea party was
coming uh
and so there was this
world that worried about inflation these
libertarians that didn't bought by the
government
there were these cypher punks that
wanted to live off the grid so there was
these constituencies
that wanted to participate in this kind
of new technology which was
really cool technology and you could
boil it down to one simple sentence
it was the first digital signature you
could encounter fit
and because of that we could have
digital money for the first time
before that i would just be like yank
sent me a yang dollar i'm going to make
5 000 of them and send them around right
but this blockchain thing
satoshi's white paper thing said if i
send you a
yang dollar it's only the yang dollar
and
that concept i was like that's really
freaking cool
and so we this new technology and all
these constituents plus the chinese were
buying i was like it's going to go up
so i bought it originally as a
speculative asset thinking
i'm a speculator i'll be smart now i
bought a lot of it
partly because i had a whole lot of
[ __ ] money you know
so when you're worth 800 million dollars
to buy three million
is it's a bet but it's you know less
than one percent of your net worth
sure what took courage was
to talk about it publicly to say
i actually think this is a
really interesting technology and i
didn't do it overnight
i was actually kind of thrust onto the
stage i
was written about in the the ft because
there were some
reporters at a conference like that
where there was i didn't think there was
press and i was waxing on about this
and then i started getting i started
getting asked to speak at the oxford
union on tv
so i had to do more homework because i
didn't look like an idiot and so as i
dug in and try to understand
and i'm not a computer science guy it
was complicated computer science
but really understand the essence and
meet the people
i realized that this was more than a
financial trick that this was a social
revolution
and it was a political revolution it was
a revolution that said
we don't trust the center we think the
world is being built unfairly
we want more transparency we want a more
egalitarian framework
uh and we want to you know we're leery
of governments we're leary of
jp morgan where they're called the rent
takers and so it had a
revolutionary spirit spirit that
resonated with me
and after i left fortress or it left me
and i dug in i really understood that
this was a
gen z and millennial middle finger
to the system that they somehow
intuitively knew that the baby boomers
were spending all the money uh
that grandpa's third hip operation was
worth more than
investing in education for the
generation that hasn't been born
and that we were blowing up deficits and
so
people like well why are all the young
kids buying it the young
this this is the social currency of gen
z and the millennials
this was a movement of young people uh
that wanted more transparency
that one something that's more fair and
so that resonated with my political
ideals
and so because i didn't think i'd ever
go back to work it's
running a family office is work but it's
really nice work
you make sure pets people come they
shine your shoes
handsome you are you make a movie every
once in a while
you do some things you invest in
non-profits like yeah it's beautiful and
so
i remember telling my team i was like
guys we've been sitting here for two
years getting our shoes shined
we're now the shoeshine boys get on your
knees and pull out the grease and start
shut because running a customer business
and really trying to build something
is is client focused and so
i wasn't going to make that decision
lightly and i made it under three
i said i need to be with young people
and
this is a young person's movement i need
to be learning something every day
and when you get into the venture world
i remember media from venture america
and i invested in a
escape group like the young energy
around adventure is fascinating
yeah because you learn every
conversation uh
and third i needed to feel like i had a
contribution to make
and i teased about being the oldest guy
in crypto but i did think there was a
contribution
to connect this crypto energy to
institutions
i mean you're one of the preeminent uh
bridge builders
and frankly in my mind like uh
stampers of legitimacy in
in many ways uh you know one
reason i connected with the
cryptocurrency community
uh when i was running for president and
i talked to you about this before
is i found that something like 98 of
cryptocurrency
investors endorsed uh
some version of universal basic income
and i i think that
one of the reasons for that overlap was
that if you invest in cryptocurrencies
you have a mindset of abundance of
optimism you think about the future and
how things can be better and you also
frankly like you know you see people
laboring in scarcity and you think huh
like maybe there's a better way because
you've seen something go from
in your case 95 to 50 000
like over a particular period of time
and then when you see people
uh you know and obviously people working
hard i mean like you know you and i
uh appreciate the value of hard work but
like the the overlap
i found between cryptocurrency investors
and folks that want to make things uh
better and more modern in terms of how
people's time gets spent like the
overlap is very very high
to understand cryptocurrencies at its
core you start thinking about new
economic models
yeah and like how would it work why
don't we use
the old bottle if it's not working and i
remember there's a guy named dan larimer
uh and i talked to him for hours about
ubi
and he had the most interesting way of
thinking about ubi
uh which was you know why
just because you're saudi arabian born
you get all the oil resources just
randomly because you were lucky to be
born on saudi arabia so
like maybe we should share share the
world's resources
uh and that if you taxed
total wealth about three percent a year
and redistributed it
uh over time with a generation and a
half you're recycling total wealth
and his idea of redistributing it wasn't
all at once it was like listen if the
five of us go to an island
and we give everyone equal sums the most
commercial guy is going to have all the
money in about 32 days
but if we leak out a little bit each day
if andrew yang's the shark the rest of
us realize
stay away from the shark after a few
bites
and so you know you can literally
because of the
technology of cryptocurrency create a
system that
pays people by the hour wow but
think about think about government you
know
you know government transfer payments
you could literally have them
being delivered by the minute wow and so
i keep thinking
there's a we've got a world that's so
disjointed the rich poor gap is as wide
as it's ever been
in history i gave a speech in 06 that
said the risk poor gap is so wide
it's going to end in revolution that was
15 years ago
and it's so much worse it skyrocketed
since then yeah
and so we need some redistribution
but government has not been a great way
to redistribute it's not efficient it's
bureaucratic
and so you can see a system of
redistribution directly
wow to wallet you know on some algorithm
that everyone kind of agreed to or the
politics agreed to uh and so
it draws crypto nerds in
because crypto nerds are about how do we
use this technology
to start reimagining things and i think
you're right abundance is a big part of
it
uh but it's also how do we reimagine
social policy
even that exchange where you highlighted
some of the possibilities
using the blockchain is incredible
i mean no wonder you talk to dad for
hours because that that'd be fascinating
i mean
that like there the need for new
economic models is so clear
uh and i think the cryptocurrency
community is light years ahead of a lot
of us
in large part because most human beings
operate
in a mindset of resource scarcity it's
kind of hardwired into us you know it's
biological
they also operate with the same mistake
i made when you said you want to be
president
with a presupposition of they know what
that means
i know what a president is supposed to
have gone through therefore
if he doesn't pick the box i short
circuit i might learn a great lesson
with your success i'm saying like wait a
minute so in crypto it's the same thing
we're operating
most people say these are the economic
tools i'm allowed to think about
and the other guys are like no no we can
make new tools
right and so it's a really interesting
you know analogy of opening up
your mind and opening up the toolkit to
say how we've got this problem
listen it's irrefutable that capitalism
is not working
yes it just isn't working it's not
working for a whole lot of people that's
for sure
yeah and so we gotta figure out a way
to make it work for the majority of
people yeah i i tried to brand this i
don't know if you read my book mike but
uh
human-centered capitalism and the goal
is instead of trying to optimize for
capital efficiency we're trying to
optimize for human well-being so that's
health mental health childhood success
rates environmental quality
uh average
affordability or you know living
standard because if you look at what's
going on in the u.s right now i think
we're 28th worldwide in
really basic standards like uh
cleanliness of drinking water
or public education like 28th is not
great and unfortunately the
trends are getting worse like one of the
things i said when i was running for
president is like you have stock market
prices at record highs what else are
record highs
indebtedness financial insecurity
suicide
uh mental health disorders like you know
i mean it's like
our our economy is
working on certain terms if your goal is
let's say gdp maximization or
stock market values but then most people
are getting left behind by it so the
goal is to
try and have new measurements that say
you know what like we should be actually
optimizing for
how people are doing and then if you did
that then all of a sudden you'd see
frankly that that there's like a
misalignment
what are the current projects that
galaxy is involved with that you're
excited about that are trying to
make bets in various ways or find new
applications
uh of these technologies we're invested
all over the ecosystem
uh the most fascinating ones right now
are the metaverse right oh tell us more
well so you're talking about nfts
these days right so what's an nft uh
an nft is but i said bitcoin was the
first
digital signature you could encounter it
so we could have unique money
well think about that with art or ip or
i've got this button right here it's
called the [ __ ] it button you could
think of this as a three-dimensional nft
that you know had funny things coming up
but that was a unique
object that some famous artists created
uh right now they're selling nfts and
you can
do what with them i don't know you can
put it on your
coinbase wallet uh or your metamask
wallet
but in the future we might have this
podcast
in your man cave your in my avatar will
meet your avatar and your whole
digital art world will be there
interesting
when you think about the automation of
work
and the gamification of life there might
be jobs in five or 10 years or 15 years
where the kid from syracuse is
actually working as a bartender in a
fake shanghaies brothel
chatting people up for bitcoin tips and
that's his full-time job
uh and so we're investing in all of
these
projects that are building these new
worlds that people are going to live in
and play it
uh from did from you know sports arenas
virtual sports arenas or concerts uh
i'm convinced that esports is going to
be as big as real sports uh within a
generation
very well could be uh travie scott
you know the the awesome rapper he gave
a concert two years ago
on fortnight the video game with a
hundred million million people showed up
at it
i mean the only times we've ever had a
hundred million people show up is like
kuba mela
you know the great hindu ceremony that
happens every 13 years
where they all go to the ganges and wash
themselves in the holy water
uh we've never had 100 million people
show up for anything
he had a hundred million people at the
same time watching his concert
that's incredible that's that's like a
mind blown now think about this
you know i become friends with the
artist's cause uh
and he did the album cover i said
college you blew it
if you had done one of your giant
floating cause balloons that flew over
that concert right in that metaverse
20 years later that thing would be worth
zillions because everyone who was at
that concert would have an emotional
memory of that concert in that balloon
and say i gotta buy that blue
like we invest value in things that
connect to us emotionally
and so nfts right now is a bubble
but having value digitally in these
goods that are unique
is to be those are going to be picassos
in the future
uh i'm positive and so from a financial
perspective
investing in that infrastructure is cool
and from a where the world's going
perspective
it's also like you know one of my my
friends who's a futurist
he thinks a third of all jobs in 30
years will be virtual ones
uh and we never thought that was in even
remotely
close and now we all work live on zoom
we're all kind of virtual workers at
this point yeah no
i mean we're all digital avatars right
now
at least a lot of us are a lot of us are
and so
you know it's interesting i think
more practically the next big wave of
change from normal people is going to be
your bank account is going to become a
wallet
right it's going to be a wallet on your
phone a crypto wallet
you're not going to have 72 different
passwords all your value is going to be
held in this crypto wallet
and it's it'll be tickets anything that
can keep me from having to remember all
these passwords
is a huge win
i try to use the same one and they don't
work i'm like i am sure no it's the
worst man it's like you've used this
password before it's like that's because
it's my
[ __ ] password
[Laughter]
and i think we're gonna have a digital
dollar and a digital remnb
and a digital brazilian rai uh
they're called stable coins or central
bank issue digital currencies
and this thing that five dollar bill
will be the
way of the dodo bird and that'll happen
in the next five to ten years
uh and it's different than the digital
money we have today
right those are closed ecosystems so if
i venmo you money
i can then get 1500 bucks but not more
and i can't do it if you're overseas
and that's just a book accounting from
you know
venmo to venmo pretty soon it's going to
be like i gave you that money and it's
no longer in my possession it's in your
possession and you'll be able to
all over the world think about it i can
take a picture of myself
in a funny position and set it in one of
40 different apps
across the world in a millisecond think
about any pixels and how complicated
picture is but i can't send money right
now
if i set your parents in taiwan money it
would take me three days and cost me a
fortune and i have to wire the money
i call my bank i don't know if your
parents are in taiwan so i made it oh
they are no that was correct
what do they think about andrew yang
america
oh you know one of my favorite stories
um mike
was i was running for president and i
was busting my ass
i was in iowa um and
i heard this story that um in taiwan
they were watching the
presidential debates uh to cheer me on i
was like the folk hero over there
and then my dad went to like a watch
party
in taipei and then said that's my son
and then everyone was like yeah that
everyone like like bought my dad a drink
and he was like the proud papa
you know at this taiwanese theater
and that gave me so much joy and
happiness because like i was
you know on the other side of the world
in iowa like trying to make it happen
and and the fact that my dad was you
know like uh
getting drinks bought for him across the
world
it made me really happy well and it
talks about how interconnected the world
has gotten
you know it's so weird as we went
through trumpism and we were like
pulling back i was like you can't pull
back
like the world is so connected pollution
in one part of the world goes to the
other part of the world right economic
chaos in one part of the world goes to
the other world virus
starts in china and now it's blowing up
in india like to think we can live
isolated
is just fools thinking oh you know i
talking to you mike it's expanded my
mind so you have your own podcast
next with novo where you have on various
folks to talk about what you see coming
um what are the best ways that people
can
keep up with you i am an active
twitterer at novogratz on twitter
uh you know it's funny because i do a
lot of criminal justice work
and i do a lot of crypto and those two
communities don't always see how
high the crypto community can be very
libertarian
uh i think it's progressive i think
crypto is progressive
uh but a lot of them are libertarian and
so they don't like my politics
uh and so it's a pretty funny twitter
because there's lots of
people so i have a twitter at no regrets
the same thing on uh
instagram and then i have this podcast
next with novo which is
i think on spotify and apple and and
youtube and uh
you know we only started a few months
ago and we just sometimes do
next with novo live i've been doing a
series with young rappers
and so i did 2c tonight who is one of
the charmingest
young 21 year olds uh
smarter than a whip but you know i've
had little yachty and
polo g and uh if you're a 20 year old
out there you know exactly what i'm
talking about
so you talked about your progressive
politics and one thing that you and i
connect on is that you're
a really active philanthropist we talked
about beat the streets which is this
wrestling organization for
underprivileged kids you're
a very active criminal justice reformer
you sponsor wrestling organizations
um of it of different kinds um can you
do you want to talk about
what else you have going on that you're
excited about philanthropically or
politically because i know you're always
trying to
do something you know we're doing we
have this thing called galaxy gibbs
i met richard branson and uh i was so
impressed that he
branded everything virgin and that gave
everything he did a certain energy and i
had already called my family office
galaxy investment partners and so we
called our crypto company galaxy digital
and we said philanthropy galaxy gives
um and we had a few different pockets
one was sports faith youth development
uh we still contribute some money there
but i got into criminal justice reform
and it just
pissed me off the deeper i dug the more
pissed i got
and so that's a big part of what we do
now i'm the chairman of the bail project
a part of the reform alliance we have
now
i think 15 galaxy leaders who are
formerly incarcerated
young men and women that we are helping
fund their organizations and creating
cohorts of learning
um we fund about 25 different
different groups besides that all around
the ecosystem
with the idea of trying to create this
army of people that see the world the
same way
and can push the ball forward um
the second so it's criminal justice on
one hand the second is democracy
you know my two guys billy uh waterson
and xander schultz
who are smarter than whips and very
stubborn
came to me and said dude none of the
[ __ ] we do in criminal justice matters
if trump gets reelected and
because he's eating away at the core of
democracy
and i'm like yeah donating and they
wanted me to donate one percent of my
net worth which was a lot of money
for the election and i was like that's
like peeing in the ocean and hoping it
gets warm
i'm like these elections gonna be five
billion dollars and
you know my money's not gonna matter and
they wouldn't let me go and they came
back with this plan
and it was a brilliant plan it was we
are going to create community
that's going to raise money to invest in
local organizers in the swing states
and our thesis of change has been
local communities know what's best for
them
don't me come in from new york city and
tell a guy in kentucky what's good for
him
let's fund the people in new york in
kentucky
so they can have a voice they can
participate in democracy
and we raised 75 million dollars in that
last election cycle
uh that's 73 million more than i thought
we'd raise i honestly thought it would
be a 2 million
or never and my team just blew me away
they put me on the phone with people
and these weren't people i knew these
weren't hedge fund guys
this was a broad community of people
that cared about democracy
uh it wasn't all democrats though
it was more democrat than republican and
what was even
more unique about this was after the
election was over
our partners said we need to keep this
going
and so now tomorrow i'm interviewing a
guy to be the executive director where's
this is a real organization now we're
already up to equal amount
over the next four-year cycle and
growing wow and
what we learned is democracy
itself the infrastructure of democracy
yes people want to make a philanthropic
category and it never was before now
incredible and so we're becoming leaders
and again that
you know the credit all goes to really
billy waterson and zander schultz
uh whom i know and i love billy
watterson and xander schultz are both
incredible people and and so my
philanthropy well it's a lot of my money
it really is their business and our
family
like you know they're part of the family
and i we're adding people to it we've
just hired
a brilliant guy who spent 25 years in
prison uh and got out three four weeks
ago
uh as a 42 year old think about that oh
my gosh
um 17 to 42. yeah
he should have got out 15 years ago
yeah uh and at least or more
a beautiful man who grew and changed and
so the the lesson i've learned from all
these visits and people is
i fundamentally believe you're not your
worst moment that people can change
and that our system our system and the
criminal justice system our
system in schooling needs to help people
deal with the trauma
they experience so they become
productive taxpayers
productive citizens engaged in society
and we have so many communities where
trauma
is 24 hours a day
and without if we recognize it and start
investing in how to help people through
trauma
uh we have much more productive you know
world yes
so you're just hiring an executive
director for this org uh
is the democracy organization
also under galaxy gives or does it have
its own uh name
it's got its own name it's called one
for democracy what we learned is
if you don't name it mike novogratz
the champion you know but if you allow
a community to own it and so while billy
started it it has been the heart and
then the acting exec director
the money got allocated by five
unbelievably knowledgeable groups
that got together and formed a committee
people that lots of experience in this
space and said
hey these are the right organizations to
give the money to we were one vote in
that
uh we did most of the fundraising uh
but you know you don't find
it's not like our names are are ahead of
anyone else's in the group and we don't
believe it's our thing to own uh so we
incubate these things and we're trying
to
help foster a community continue to fund
them and
let them exist on their own because i
think it's a much more powerful way
to have change the world doesn't want a
bunch of billionaires dictating
how the world goes they want people
who think about things and you know the
the philanthropists are supposed to be
helping where they can
but it's a very funny play between being
a leader
and in out front of the troops and being
a leader
in in empowering the troops yeah it's
something i'm getting used to
like i'm a big personality i like to be
on tv i'd like to
have an opinion but what i've seen is
we've had more success
when the other guys are in front and i'm
uh every once in a while parachuting in
well kudos to you for investing in our
democracy mike because it needs it
you know anyone who thinks our democracy
is just gonna sustain itself without
some
uh really frankly like consistent
investment
and people rolling up their sleeves and
working on it i mean
hopefully everyone realizes that that's
the task like i'm deeply concerned about
uh our democracy's uh
progression through this time of really
epic
and uh accelerating change um so
congratulations to you for being one of
the people that's actually investing in
it and not expecting things to just go
well without us
uh i i again i know billy and xander and
they're great great
thinkers on this and i think everyone
listening to this appreciates your
desire to let
other people um lead it's very
democratic really you know what i mean
you're not like hey this is our thing
i got to say man like one of the reasons
i appreciate you is that
you're you're so young at heart uh it's
awesome
uh you know i i think that's going to
keep you happy
vibrant ahead of the curve or into the
future i've had some similar experiences
too where i've worked with young people
a lot over the last number of years and
i think it's helped keep me
um optimistic uh you're a force for
progress my friend um so psyched so
people want to catch up with mike
novogratz it's next with novo
you learned a lot from this i know
you'll learn a lot from mike over time i
learned a lot and uh you know i'm going
to consider mike someone i turn to
to see what's coming next thank you mike
thank you my friend it's been great
hanging out with you
lots of fun on a saturday night
[Music]
you